cuz by the way you know Biden has gotten
to a point where it's almost a little
fun now for the people around him cuz it
is like a weekend at Bernie yeah it is
kind of fun because he's like
essentially just almost at the death's
door and they're all now like we're all
in this together oh he's like death Dash
It's death Dash they're in it together
now so it's kind of like we can't get
out it's kind of fun like late nights
just propping them up like playing with
him like a puppet and going like we're
just going to put him out on the debate
stage like giving them good drugs inject
like the injections that Biden gets
before the first debate it will be
nothing you've ever heard like teams of
people you ever see the scene in ET
where they put a tent around and they
won't let anyone near it before Biden
walks on that debate stage there's going
to be an ET like tent and just people in
hazmat suits are going to go in and just
start injecting him with things and then
he's just going to walk out like a
regular person and then you're going to
go oh there's [__] we have no idea about
he's going to have a dip in in his cheek
of 's hair yeah he's going to just start
boxing like he's going to come out
they're going to be
like he'll start like throwing hands be
like there are drugs we've never heard
like there's technology we've never
heard of there are drugs we've never
heard of oh they're going to be pumping
they're gonna be playing TI they're GNA
be doing anything they GNA be like
they'll they'll be say have a Ouija
board channeling corn poop from the
[__] swimming pool they're going to
be do you can you imagine like doing
debate prep with him how nervous they're
going to be they're going to be sitting
there and they're going to be like okay
and then they're going to call like the
people in like the Deep State and stuff
they're going to go we got to we got to
really up up the dose here we're not I
mean like he's not responding to the
regular
stimuli need to really get in here with
something like really intense because he
just left the room we just asked him a
question he just walked out of the room
he doesn't know where he is so like we
got to like play around with a cocktail
of things to just get him to a point
where he stand at the put him on the
AIDS meds they're going to have him on
everything you can be on dude he is the
crazy thing is imagine the scripts will
be practicing with him the week before
Oh my God probably it'll just be
monologues from famous movies oh my God
it's going to be things Tony Soprano
said they're like if if you forget just
give this speech that Tony Soprano gave
to Anthony about World War II just if
that's the closest you can get to this
question question read this
scene from The Sopranos where Tony
talked about the importance of Italian
Americans during World War II it's gonna
be dude he's gonna be reading monologues
from the movie hooers whenever Jean
Hackman try to get Jimmy Chitwood to run
the picket fence it's GNA be
unbelievable unbelievable by the way
that first debate I will be watching
just like there's nothing more
entertaining and that it's the Super
Bowl for someone like me to just watch
that go down it's old versus orange baby
it's old versus orange and it's just
they're both wild like Trump's GNA be
just popping off because now Trump's
also four years older he doesn't even
care anymore and who's more likely to
even say the nword now it's different
reason I know because one could just
bubble out a [__] Biden or Trump
could just fire one off that he earned
back in the Dayal candidate said the n
in the debate well if they did at the
same time I think it's what we all want
to hear yeah but if that's a good point
if they just both said it at the exact
same time then it would just be a reset
then the country like at that point if
they if Trump and Biden say the nword at
the same time in that debate the
Israelis and the Palestinians are just
going to look at each other and start
embracing yeah they'll hug because
that's what we need really oh it's
exactly what we need man if Bobby
Kennedy Jr was out there and got to
debate either one of them I think he
would crush them Bobby Kennedy Jr I
think would
absolutely wreak havoc in a debate he
should be out there why can't he debate
he's an independent candidate right they
just these big parties try to keep
everybody out because people try to get
in there like it you know what I mean
like people try to get in there like
like people just like I think Ben Glee
was trying to like run for president
like so they just try to keep people out
because it could get real wild yeah you
know like the third party candidates get
kind of get wild oh definitely that's
true you like you you'd have a bunch of
you'd have like one of the Real
Housewives you have an only fans model
on there some only fans model would get
out there yeah for the Real Housewives
she'd get out there you know and so like
you you you Charleston white probably
would be out there hopefully you're
right this [__] out there jeus huh wow
it looks like the [__] it literally
reminds me of uh like the Muppets went
to [__]
makeup but that's the problem like so
that like here's the thing like as much
as I don't think it's fair that they're
keeping Bobby Kennedy out they do need
to keep certain people out right CU it
would just be a waste of time yeah Glee
bran in
2020 how did he do I don't know yeah how
did he do do we do was there I don't
know it's such a brave thing to do is
it that's a good question what does
brave mean I don't know I think it's
Brave if you get to a certain level
right but if most people don't know you
did it right he's not that brave well
Trump could go Trump could go get
arrested I don't think it'll happen I
think a lot of charges are really
trumped up they're all [__] they're
all like he inflated the price of a
toilet he bought in Mora it's the most
ridiculous chares he also does have
they're like he said it was marble it's
actually Granite it's like guys remember
you told us that he was like the Russian
president and they couldn't prove any of
that and now they're like he said it was
quartsite it's just quartz that's a
man-made Stone you're like guys you went
left on this yeah just didn't really
just didn't work out I wish you would
have started that I I would believe that
he [__] that that he that he uh shcks
at a couple of right uh Construction
Company 100% countertops that part 100%
yeah but he he he could have some
complications with that but Biden could
pass away Biden has passed away Biden
there we know what they're going to try
to do to him oh they're going to have
him japed up they're going to have a
[__] uh fizer is going to get
involved they're going to get involved
and so you have this interesting
scenario where you have one candidate
who's may be in jail and the other
candidate is on like an experimental new
cocktail of
drugs no we don't know the side effect
we have no idea what's about happen they
could be roller skating racism could
levitate chewing on your Tong we don't
know what's going to happen we don't
know what and they the scientists by the
way make no mistake scientists at fisa
right now are sitting there with members
of the Biden campaign and going we
here's the bad news we don't know what
happens after we know it gives him
energy we know it makes him clear-headed
we know it gives him uh the ability to
speak what can his valves handle is
asking what PSI what PSI can his aort
handle right now we don't know what else
happened so you know we don't have an
option we're just shooting them up with
just putting them on stage do they have
to debate each other does that have to
happen I imagine that it will and they
you know when it terms how you got to
somebody smarter than me would know MH
it's happened every single election it'd
be weird if it didn't happen be very
weird wow it would be very weird and
what and and anyone could throw their
hat in at the last minute oh like
Bloomberg tried to do remember that
little Mau anyone could come in and just
it's yours now I mean somebody could try
Bloomberg got shellacked yeah gav might
try even though he's hated he's like on
a Vineyard he's [__] he's on a
Vineyard somewhere just one drunk
telling people he's the president just
watching home cameras making sure
there's no squaders heading Michelle
Obama could get involved I don't think
she would win though she I
think had uh some heat but it's kind of
like died down well if Trump say if
Trump went to a jail or something
happened they made it so he couldn't run
and if Biden is too old to run Kennedy
if he could get in could actually
[__] win that's the part dude a
th%